another night and another area of Hong
Kong is the site of confrontation this
time
the shopping district of Kowloon on the
northern side of Hong Kong harbour
protests had started calmly tens of
thousands walking a route approved by
police but thousands branched off and
they'd clearly come prepared for
violence you've come with a gas mask
with a helmet you've hidden your face
why afraid that after all the protests
protests and I mean I will become the
one who be arrested
what are you provoking the police by
coming dressed like this
are you wanting violence no I don't want
violence but only protecting myself
these protests began back in June with
specific demands that proposed laws
allowing people to be extradited to
mainland China be scrapped now though
these protests are about political
reform democracy so this is no longer
about the extradition laws no no longer
again
I mean maybe is about its traditional
two months ago but now is about our
democracy we Rudy space we honk on it
we Hong Kong and our China government
I'm not British but the protests are
also now about expressing anger towards
the policing of previous events this
police station became the focal point on
Saturday with people hurling rocks at
the compound leaving cars smashed inside
and lighting fires after an hour under
siege came the inevitable confrontation
the police have now moved in you can see
them firing teargas and the crowd is
moving fast
the remor protest planned for Sunday
there are calls for a general strike on
Monday it's impossible to know how or
when Hong Kong will return to normal
Hong Kong people lose their satisfaction
to the government and now is the summer
of this content discontent which on
Saturday yet again turned ugly Andrew
Thomas al Jazeera Hong Kong